god we were gonna blow each other up so
many times I can blow myself what
there's a greatest day of my life
whoa egg launcher what the [ __ ] all
right so it's very fitting that we go to
flush
if we don't good landing tilted towers
I'm gonna cut your dick off all right
we're gonna - no we don't have to come I
know that sounds very I hope I'm going
to the right place also are you saying
we should go - flush because we are
giant pieces of [ __ ] is that what you're
saying take it they took you out yeah
was flush wait were we in the rough oh I
was not even the red city see this is
why I was supposed to cut your dick off
so you were all like it was all like
tile if you don't get one kill we're all
gonna take off do it do it man do it man
yeah yeah you get to keep your dick more
kills equals more dick no no it's like
every kill you get one inch to save so
you're good all right I believe in you
you're the best you're wonderful you're
beautiful human being can't wait to see
you succeed in life everything that you
have going for you is great you're
shining beacon of humanity you're
handsome
god oh you're being very distracting
shut the [ __ ] up with your compliments I
am concentrating here I know I'm
handsome you shut your goddamn ugly
mouth oh yeah there there oh you're in
trouble
thank dodge let's do that let's
definitely do that I mean I guess if we
really want to wait now our teammates
are gonna be all kinds of they might you
know my voice is not very enticing
people hear my voice they want to push
me it's a curse I can't help it is that
like fapping but what it felt yes I
can't fat my way through this problem
man
what [ __ ] blow up or blow you want to
blow yourself up
God if I could if I could man you don't
understand what I hope and pray for
every single night before I go to bed
just please take out some vertebrae give
me that flexibility is it is it a
vertebrae or ribs just you're asking me
whatever you can Lord above please just
make my head at crotch level please
oh my god everyone else is here I'm
sorry teammates I'm sorry
oh my guys real markiplier it is yes it
is are where are we going where are we
going alright
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't know how hard I'm trying right
now so far up your ass
so worried oh this is right over - oh
hell yeah you know it's gonna be good
there are so many people that are I'm
ready to die
Tyler wait I'm coming to you I'm coming
baby my baby boy I didn't get the kills
oh your dick is gone oh you got you got
the sweets I'm sorry guys I was shook
god I can't if I go out in the open okay
that's one I feel like the entire time
we're just screaming I'm pretty sure it
like is there anything there's nothing
different in any of my other videos so
here we go
let's go for it let's do this
man let me try to barter with this guy
that's a guided missile then it's just
as comprehensible as our yelling I guess
oh that's a guy we got this I'm jerking
off you remember back in our wrestling
days when I would get psyched up to go
out there wrestle real good you remember
we would do it together to each other
you don't remember that do you remember
watching me oh yeah that's right you
remember watching me alone in the
showers I'm gonna do sick maneuvers are
you ready okay here we go I don't know
how this work I've never yah huh guys
everyone in chat guys guys listen listen
listen listen listen you're on subbing I
understand I am not good at this game
but but but we all knew that it's like
when I said at PAX in the panel you got
to start at rock bottom and believe in
your stuff you got to keep trying no
matter what you got to get back on the
horse
gotcha I can't shoot it out wait I could
I can make a window now I'll make a
window and then I'll make a ceiling I'll
shoot out the window watch this oh yeah
I'm coming in although alright pro-gamer
out oh we're coming for you baby oh it's
happening oh baby oh baby oh yeah this
seems ridiculously overpowered how is
this noise it's like still okay is that
my dude sama dude is that my dude he
didn't get the roof on in time I got
right there I see okay well this is
gonna be a it's gonna be a trip oh the
tree don't worry I got you covered
Claudia he's still in that Bush yep
[Laughter]
I got a jump pad I'll be fine Oh boom
you're getting shot oh maybe maybe
pro-gamer Alf can get me but probably
not
[Laughter]
[Music]